as Moore mentioned you can also focus
your segmentation on a persona personas
are fictional characters created to
represent different user types that are
going to use your product in a very
similar way so the best practice is to
define three to five different personas
and describing them as if they're real
people so with a name a job values what
are their hobbies and maybe even a quote
that the user might say we'll use these
to create an actual profile for each
persona
let's take YouTube kids for example this
is art he's a dad and as much as he
would love to expose his son to all
different content music he really wants
to make sure that his son only consumes
age-appropriate content and this is Finn
his son he's three years old he wants to
watch YouTube all day long and he wants
to do everything by himself he needs an
interface that's going to allow him to
do it himself and be easy to navigate
these are two personas art is our
decision maker so as a company YouTube
needs to get art to trust in their
product with his son and Finn needs an
app that he actually enjoys using so a
persona for abarkment could be Dahlia a
twenty nine-year-old finance executive
who frequently travels for business when
she's not working she loves the outdoors
trying new upscale restaurants cooking
and of course spending time with her
golden doodle who she considers a child
in a business business example creating
a persona can be a little bit more
complex you really have to understand
the business you're targeting and the
individual constraints of each user and
decision maker so the user could be a
marketing person or an engineer but the
decision maker could be someone more
senior level like the CEO or CFO